hello folks welcome to rational science
directly from Germany by the way we're
having a very cold
White Christmas over here okay yeah it's
gonna be a white Christmas
anyways uh Argentina won the
championship uh soccer championship and
some people asked me
what I think about that and what can I
say you know it's um
it's all about flag waving and singing
national anthems it's got a lot to do
with nationalism
and I got a problem with nationalism uh
because my experience is that you know
uh what you can do for your country is
one thing what your country can do for
you
is in my experience never happened okay
and politicians at a given moment they
do whatever they need to do to stay in
power or to make money or whatever so
they won't do anything for you and at
that moment in time they are the country
okay the country you're trying to defend
so yeah it's all about flag waving uh
national anthems you know when you go to
all these uh Olympics and soccer and
whatever International
championships where countries are
competing it's all about nationalism
that's all it is
and talking about what your country can
do for you here we have a gentleman his
name was John F Kennedy John Fitzgerald
Kennedy and apparently the other day
they released
some more documents and we're talking
about
1963. I remember it well because I mean
I think anyone in those days remembers
it well and I was only 11 years old and
still I remember very well what happened
that day anyways they released some
documents now almost 60 years old and
essentially they're trying to find out
if there's any information there that
would clarify the situation and I'm
saying of course not uh the only purpose
of holding all this is so that they can
have or at least the effect right is so
that the government can later say well
the reason we were withholding all this
is because we were trying to
um hide our operational secrets
you know and uh so there won't be any
information regarding uh Lee Harvey
Oswald or or whatever happened 60 years
ago
um you know that's that's a separate
issue this the separate issue and and
all I can tell you is how I look at it
that I say that those three gentlemen at
the bottom were at the top of the uh
conspiracy to kill Kennedy lots of
people involved hundreds okay and
um and this is my take on it just my
personal take of uh things that made me
think that these gentlemen were the ones
who uh did the whole operation here it
is uh just a snapshot things that came
out of my mind okay I'm sure there's a
lot more than these but you know the
Magic Bullet I don't buy it it's against
physics uh it's nonsense that the United
States government had to put out there
to uh have some kind of theory uh
everyone running up the grass you know
Uncle Sam collecting cameras in Dealey
Plaza uh films that they never gave back
a lot of people complained about that
they said they had film stuff and it
never came back to them it's a Pruder
for them uh one that eventually reached
the public a little too late uh that's
one issue but then they uh took out some
of the first few frames
and I think that those were important
okay Parkland uh hospital they denied
the doctors who were working on Kennedy
to do an autopsy they took the body out
of there or like
um the movie says the JFK movie says it
was a uh a getaway they were running
with the uh cadaver all the way to
Maryland
Oswald he was a naval intelligence in
Naval intelligence uh they sent them to
the Soviet Union who knows for what uh
when he came back allegedly you know uh
uh came back to the United States and uh
no one debriefed them I mean here's you
have an intelligence officer he leaves
the United States he comes back and it's
just everything's hunky-dory no problem
and then uh obviously there's a
connection between George Bush father
right he was CIA he claims he wasn't at
the time but it turns out that George
the [ __ ] Shield the guy who got Oswald
his uh job at The Book Depository
um he he wrote a letter to Bush and Bush
answered him so they knew each other
okay and uh and
you got to look up the morning Shield to
find out how they also knew each other
from the past anyways uh more and shield
Oswald and George Bush now that's a big
coincidence there you know tremendous
one for me assassination of key
Witnesses and uh others uh like Caleb
Boggs uh his plane went down
uh Charles nicoletti and uh Martin
Shield they they were murdered on the
same day I'm sorry they suicided
themselves uh 10 shots in the head I
think it was Martin Shield uh I'm sorry
uh nicoletti uh I I think they put him
in a one of those cement uh barrels and
you know send them down down the ocean
or maybe that was Johnny roselli who
knows anymore Lee Bauer is a guy who was
at the tower looking down at the grass
you know they had to get rid of him all
these people by the way uh nicoletti and
Morin Shield deep Bowers they were all
about to testify uh nicoletti was I'm
not sure about the [ __ ] Shield uh
William fitzger the guy who took
pictures over there at the naval uh
Hospital you know he um he took pictures
he wasn't supposed to
and Sam giancana Johnny roselli you know
those those people They Knew Too Much
they had to get rid of them uh
kilgallon same she was a reporter and
they had to get rid of all these people
anyways uh the doctor photos no doubt
about that
um limo protected at uh Parkland you
know they uh they didn't let anybody
near the car and then they transferred
and refurbished it uh essentially
destroying all the evidence that's what
they were up to and Ruby Mafia who was a
guy who was given you know the contract
uh either he killed Oswald they went
after him and then the Warren Commission
uh they stacked the you know the uh
whole uh supposed commission this jury
right this uh judge slash jury where
people like Ford and Dulles and Specter
so you know those are my first uh off
the head things that showed me that this
was a US Government operation no doubt
about it anyways
um talking about U.S government
operations one guy says Russia blew up
their own pipelines referring to the
north stream 2 pipeline to serve gas
prom from infinite arbitration suits uh
well I think we need to
um
look at
um
something that Biden said a few months
ago and uh throws the ball squarely in
the hands of the United States it's the
United States who has to prove now that
they did not do North stream too okay
not that they did but it the onus the
burden of proof is on the United States
and here here's uh What uh Biden said if
Russia invades that means tanks or
troops crossing the uh the the border of
Ukraine again then uh there will be uh
we there will be no longer a North
stream too we we will bring it into it
what do what how would you how will you
do that
exactly since the project and control of
the project is within Germany's controls
we will uh I promise you we'll be able
to do it
okay so uh the ball is in the uh in
Biden's court right now not in Putin's
court and if the United States did it or
did it through one of its proxies be it
Israel or or the great uh United Kingdom
uh you know it just shows uh I mean if
that's ever proven right then we have a
case of terrorism
so let's hope they hide uh their tracks
well
anyways uh here's another fellow he says
uh USA has only been an empire for 50 to
110 years maximum in fact another fellow
said the other day that Empire's last uh
like 400 years and the United States or
350 and the United States has been
running for 345. so more or less what
this fall said well uh actually uh the
Monroe Doctrine 1823 to answer this
gentleman uh the European powers are
obligated to respect the Western
Hemisphere as the United States sphere
of Interest okay so uh anything in um in
uh in the Americas belongs to the United
States since 1823 they were giving a
word of warning to the Europeans don't
intervene here because uh you're going
to mess with us okay that's essentially
what it was and um
this is the map today okay this is how
the Empire has expanded the blue parts
are the American Empire uh you have like
an Arab Empire uh really a loose uh
Coalition of Arab countries uh there are
more countries in that that speak era
but these are the the ones that are
actually
um like in a single block you could say
and of course they're they're fighting
even within them uh but these are the
countries that um right now control the
oil the petroleum and United States and
other countries are trying to get to it
or get favorable uh you know uh deals
uh on the other side you see China in
red uh and uh Russia big Russia there
Big Country
and those are the three main Empires on
the Earth today uh India well it's not
really an Empire it's not big military
or economically
um but since it's got a lot of people a
lot of countries are interested in
selling to India at least you know or
having Commerce with them and that's
more or less a state of the world today
you have countries like Japan Australia
out there in the uh East that the United
that are friendly with the United States
together with maybe
um Thailand and Philippines and then you
have the situation where you know China
is expanding especially its military and
at some point I think there's going to
be a clash between these two empires now
will there be a uh will the U.S Empire
come to an end and China surpasses it
absolutely not okay no way that that's
ever going to happen in my opinion the
United States is going to make sure that
China does not surpass it militarily
okay and one of the problems there is
that China's in its own region whereas
the United States has to send all kinds
of uh ships especially to that region to
more or less protect uh you know Taiwan
Japan uh Australia and so on and so the
question is whether it's going to be
India ultimately a question of money
whether the United States can support
all the military uh installations that
it's going to need to uh hold
China back
so we'll just have to see what happens
uh but right now I see that that's
gearing up
you know it's uh taking wind and I think
at some point china and United States
will be confronting each other in a
little more than just economic uh
economically or in economic ways and
here let me give you a reason why I also
think that here is Good Old Germany okay
and serious military started uh or
isolated a hundred billion dollars that
they're going to be investing in weapons
here's one of the powers right after
World War II that was told not to have
weapons or to have a big military and
now the opposite is occurring a big
change in the politics of Germany
they're going to start investing in
um
in weapons and not for Ukraine they're
investing for weapons for themselves as
it says there and then uh not only them
but look at we have Japan as well just
in case another of the losers in World
War II and they're investing 300 billion
dollars in weapons when they said they
are gonna they will go to war no more or
like um who was it Chief Joseph uh one
of the uh Indian tribes in the United
States American Indians and he says I
will fight no more forevermore and Japan
said that but they changed their minds
now that you invest 300 billion dollars
in weapons to fight perhaps China but
you never know you know sometimes uh
these alliances change and uh countries
or the politicians of those countries
backstab those of the other country
happens all the time it happened
throughout history will Japan be an
enemy of the United States will Germany
ever be a enemy of the United States
well we don't know what's coming up
maybe some rightist groups take over
Germany you know maybe some kamikazes or
whatever take over Japan so you never
know what happens in countries you don't
even know uh if the United States might
have a big change of heart and uh start
laying off the
liberalism and go completely in the
other direction
so we don't know what happens but uh uh
everybody's gearing up for some kind of
War because everybody's buying weapons
right now
okay and uh final issue says altered
behavior and roles of the Sexes okay uh
you know what's going on today all this
uh talk about you know transsexuals and
homosexuals and so on I guess he was
referring primarily to that and so he
says or he thinks that all this is due
to what brain damage done with birthing
procedures injections all throughout
infancy endocrine disruption this
erupters in food and water
and a lot of people think like he does
in other words a lot of people think
that a lot of what's going on as far as
uh the social behavior the big change in
social behavior we see out there
is related to environment and
um the food that we eat
so they think it's primarily due to
those things that you know it's these
big pharmaceutical corporations that are
just feeding us nonsense or garbage in
the uh drugs that they that the doctors
prescribe for us and then the food is
all poisons got all these uh things that
they spray out there in the fields and
so on so they have this idea that it's
all food and environment
I take a different view okay completely
different view I'm saying that's got
maybe something to do with it but I'd
say very little I think it's something
else and nobody seems to be identifying
it so you're going to hear it here
because nobody else talks about it there
no geneticists no doctors no uh end of
the world uh Fanatics you know none of
those people talk about it I talk about
it because I think it's part of the
process that's going on right now and
here's a snapshot of that a picture of
that okay this is the global population
the last hundred thousand years we have
been inbreeding for over 200 300 000
years you know our first forefathers to
which we could trace our lineage could
be you anywhere between 200 and 300 000
years ago here I only put for a hundred
thousand years because otherwise I'd
have to stretch that line almost as a
straight line to the end of time to
infinity and so here you only have a
hundred thousand years but you can see
what's happened to population it's grown
tremendously in the last 200 years on
the planet and we probably in the last
200 years have had more population than
in all of history before that okay and
we were hunter-gatherers for most of
that time so small populations they just
hunted whatever they found out there
killed at eight and live one more day
about ten thousand years ago thereabouts
uh we went into agriculture we started
multiplying a little faster okay because
we were able to predict you know how
much food there was we could have
children more children you know and so
on and uh after manufacturing that's
when our population took off okay and
now in Services it's coming down again
it's approaching asymptote one more time
but the point here is that for over 200
000 years if that's where we can trace
our lineage to to you know the first
humans that to which we can still relate
to with which we could still have
children if we had sex with them you
know reproductive sex
um we've been inbreeding ever since you
know we haven't had any uh input of new
genes from monkeys or Elephants or you
know uh fruit flies
so uh my point here is that you can't
inbreed
Mother Nature's uh mechanism to stop
maybe population growth or to limit the
uh infinity you could say The Eternity
of a species is ultimately
um genetics okay you can't continue
forever because the more you inbreed the
more the children that come out of that
process are going to have uh genetic
problems
and I think that's where we're headed
and the only reason that's not going to
kill humanity is because the economy is
going to fall first that's my theory I'm
saying that the global economy is going
to collapse first and we don't have to
worry too much about
um dying in a what is known as a
background Extinction where our species
alone you know goes poof now
um
I think it's going to be the economy of
the world that's going to beat that and
when that happens not it but when that
happens we're going to take all the
mammals with us we're going to kill
everything out there so it's got to be
the end of the mammals as well
uh that's my uh heartwarming picture for
you for this Christmas okay
okay let's move on to plasma I was gonna
discuss something else today but it
turns out that uh some students fell
behind they didn't understand
they didn't understand your Arguments
for plasma okay and so what I did was I
got some of their comments and I'm going
to be addressing some of their comments
um
as well as rehashing some of the
arguments for plasma okay so here was
one comment first in Maine he said uh so
a snapshot of plasma is just gas then
okay because you have uh you know these
three states of matter which are solids
liquids and gases okay and and then
there are some people especially the
electric Universe folk uh the
thunderbolters they claim that there's
something called the fourth state of
matter and they call it plasma and they
say that uh again that's the fourth
state and so the question is uh foul
says if we take a snapshot of plasma
like you know I work with plasma and you
could see it through some of these
um Windows the machines have so you
could see you know some of the
sputtering in there some of the what was
going on in there what if I took a
snapshot of that okay or we send Adam
man he goes in there takes a snapshot of
so-called plasma what would you get
well for sure we wouldn't get plasma
you say well hold it just took a picture
of it Bill what do you mean you won't
get plasma yeah you won't get plasma and
uh the reason is that you have to look
at language
and people forget about the language
they say I just took a I just wanted to
show that in physics we can take a
snapshot of plasma now you cannot not in
science maybe an everyday speech you can
but not in science in science plasma is
defined as a process
you cannot take a snapshot of a process
of any kind of process okay you take a
snapshot of a machine that's running and
all you have is a picture of machine you
don't have it running
and plasma is a machine that's running
you can take a picture of the machine
but not if it's running and plasma is
the Running part it's a process of
ionization constant ionization so when
you take a picture of plasma you have
nothing you don't have a guess you do
not have a um because a gas is just the
atoms there without any ionization you
have a you don't have a gas you don't
have liquid and you don't have solid
what you have is
whatever invent a word for it for sure
it's not plasma because plasma is
defined as a process of ionization
that's why you haven't taken a picture
of plasma you take a picture of ionized
gas but you know we don't even know that
because all we see is little assuming we
take the quantum version all we see is
electrons here and uh protons or
hydrogen atoms or whatever over there
that's all you see okay and what is that
well we have no word for that okay okay
because plasma again is a process a
movie okay that's the problem okay
another fellow he gave it his best shot
says if I take a picture of the chair
then of it burning then of the ashes
what is it then
haha okay it's uh burnt wood
[Laughter]
we could use some of that here in
Germany it's cold out here you burn some
wood and then he says you are saying
that state is an event
in a state of matter
my God poor fellow I I think he he got
the uh scarecrow's brain that's awesome
uh poor fella yeah no it's not an event
in fact I argued exactly the opposite
what he was listening to I have no idea
okay here's another says introducing
movement into the state of matter is
irrelevant
aha
I guess his religion went down the drain
and so he got a fight for plasma until
the end of his life and so will
everybody who's been educated on the
basis of plasma they will never release
plasma because their whole religion is
over over you know
that is their icon that is their God you
can't take plasma away from them because
they're dead essentially
okay so um uh what's the problem yeah of
course uh you know there's no way
they're gonna get into the discussion
whether the word state
represents motion or the word state is a
single frame in the Universal movie
that's the whole issue and if plasma is
a state it better be a single
um frame in the Universal movie and if
it ain't because it's a process because
it's an action of some kind some kind of
movement it's a movie
then it's it can't be put into a single
frame and therefore it can't be a state
because that is what a state is a single
frame okay and uh in fact this fellow I
think uh I think it was him he goes in
and he goes in there and starts talking
about motion liquids gases solids are
states of matter okay when heated
immediately talks about heat okay the
standard model recognizes hydrogen as
being gas but when heated
so the first thing everybody wants to do
is move it around they heat it and do
other fancy things that we'll find out
in a minute here I don't want to get
ahead of myself but yeah there's
immediately they're going to move it
they're going to do some motion they're
going to talk about motion okay because
you can't talk about plasma you can't
even get to plasma until you do some
motion and then plasma itself
you know is not a cross-section of time
it requires two frames of the movie
because it is a process plasma embodies
motion uh which gas liquid and solid do
not that's the difference between them
okay okay and uh here's gas
yeah hey uh people think that uh gas is
something that's moving well this gas
moving and then in that still image I
took a snapshot of gas to to examples
is anything moving in in those uh to
snapshots those two pictures those two
still images
so no we do not need to have heat gas or
do anything or see it moving in order to
call it gas I can see in fact I showed
that to anybody and I asked them
uh what would you put that under would
you put that under solids liquids or
gases
and probably just about everyone with a
little bit of brain would say well that
looks like a gas to me
but it's not moving yeah but it still
looks like a gas to me it could be smoke
it could be vapor
could be who knows what but what you're
staring at is a still image of
um
of a gas that's what it is that's not a
solid nobody would confuse that for a
solid or for a liquid everybody would
say well it looks like gas that's what
they would say I mean straightforward uh
no run around okay you don't need motion
okay so
um
another file says I think it was the
same phone maybe I don't know but hot
energetic surface of the Sun is creating
plasma hydrogen becomes plasma yeah they
start talking about creating and becomes
and reminded me of a movie Death Becomes
Her these people don't understand the
word becomes
okay uh and and what it is is they don't
want to get involved in grammar they say
look I didn't come here to do grammar I
came here to do physics but they don't
realize that physics is 150 grammar
science is 100 grammar you better Define
your terms before you
um you do physics okay that's the
problem and some people say Bill you're
inventing your own dictionary
you can't do that
it's exactly the opposite
it's exactly the opposite in science you
must
Define your terms you have to bring your
personal dictionary
let me repeat that because people say oh
you got to use the dictionary everybody
uses so we can follow you uh-uh it's the
other way around in order to follow me
I'm going to present you my definitions
the one that I'm going to use in my
presentation my dissertation and I'm
going to define those terms if you don't
like those terms
you can't say well that's not what it
says in the dictionary that's not what
all the mathematicians at the math club
voted for that's not what I was taught
in school that's not what the
authoritative uh you know authorities
out there uh say these words mean
none of that has anything to do with
with science in science you must Define
your own terms if they're the terms if
you're going to use the terms that are
out there no problem we can accept them
uh you know at face value
but now comes you know the the criticism
now you have to defend your definition
so if you're going to use a definition
that you found in the Wikipedia or in
the dictionary or in some kind of
Encyclopedia of sorts no problem bring
whatever word that you are going to use
you better know something about that
word if it's a critical one that makes
or breaks your theory because we're
going to try to destroy it if it's
irrational and you can't say well that's
how we always used it we don't care how
it's always used we don't use democracy
we don't vote for for definitions uh
Authority uh none of that or tradition
none of that is a valid argument or that
you can say the etymology began over
here we don't care we don't care in
science who created the word in fact all
the words that were created by our
forefathers hundreds of years ago are
almost all wrong okay they're all
irrational they cannot be used in
science in ordinary speech you can use
whatever you want but in science we are
going to go after your words so yes
please bring your personal dictionary
those are the only ones that we will
accept we will not accept you using
tradition in our 30 and saying well
that's what I found in the dictionary
that's not an excuse you should know
better
okay
um
so yeah you have to Define your own
terms anyways uh what fellow said today
says PBS literally contradicted you the
very next day
uh-huh uh regarding plasma whether it
was a uh the fourth state of matter
right and so uh you have the PBS guy
Matt oh Dowd they're speaking about why
plasma is the fourth state of matter he
was trying to justify it didn't do a
good job at all and so this all says you
don't believe temperature or pressure
even though you could have seen it
yourself
marrow down uh the uh post right of uh
this PBS I think it's called space-time
program
um he essentially said you know uh
plasma is created becoming you know
becoming Death Becomes Her
um through temperature and pressure
okay so you need these two actions these
two physical phenomena to create plasma
temperature and or pressure okay so this
is what this fellow brought up okay so
let's look at what Mr O'Dowd had to say
yeah here he is
says the following says heat a block of
ice
and it melts into liquid water okay so
you have a block of ice you heat it and
turns into water keep heating it until
it boils into gas right and now you have
water vapor okay so you have these three
states of matter how did he accomplish
them well he did it through heating but
he says it's not just temperature that
determines the state of matter it is
also pressure
okay pressure what is pressure is
pressure can you take a picture of
pressure
a snapshot of pressure
can you take a snapshot of heat
of temperature no obviously not because
those are things in Motion in the case
of uh uh in the case of temperature what
you have is vibrations right and which
vibrating is actually you know heat is
the vibration of the of the Rope what it
is is the torsion of many ropes at a
higher frequency that's all heat is
under the Rope model and then uh
pressure is just atoms against atoms
okay so there is motion there you know
you have compression okay so uh he said
he just did the same thing as everybody
else he does uh odaud does not
understand that plasma is not the fourth
state because state
is a static image and he's going to talk
about pressure and heat which he cannot
synthesize in a single frame of the
universal movie
okay so here we have
um
my answer to him in a way okay
do we need to have pressure or do we
need to have heat
to talk about the category known as
solids a solid okay here's the
definition I found having three
dimensions
ninth with an i uh as a geometric uh
body or figure
okay where was the motion where was the
pressure where was the temperature
is it in there anywhere no we don't need
the word temperature the word pressure
to define the word solid
we say table it belongs to solids why
does it belong to solid because it's
well three-dimensional and geometric uh
body or figure which is not totally true
because uh solid uh can be you know in
the case of geometry they had solids
which are cubes ideal cubes and they are
not 3D in the sense that like you can
put them out here okay but just keep
that in mind I can have a 3D
visualization of a cube out there and
doesn't have to be uh it is 3D
conceptually okay so that's all you need
to be aware of but anyways having
relative firmness coherence of particles
and Persistence of form okay so yeah in
fact if you put pressure or uh heat you
may not end up with a solid depending on
how fast and how much okay so yeah for
the definitions of the categories solid
liquid gas you do not need temperature
pressure or any of the things that Mr
Matt O'Dowd mentioned
okay
um
give me a second here
okay here we have uh fellow and he uh
gives us an idea
what a state is and uh so listen to him
he he I think he's put it out very well
he says the following says a state does
not include anything about its uh the
systems history
okay so you do not need a history of
something to talk about a state you do
about plasma you do about ionization but
you do not need about uh to have a
history that underlies the word State
okay it says the path how the point Mass
got from A to point B is not a state
correct state is the condition of the
system at a given time correct given
time is a cross section of time that's a
given time you freeze the universe you
um you cut the you cut the tape of the
universe the videotape the universal
movie at one tape only at one frame only
and there we have that at the bottom
okay ionization is an example uh process
process history okay uh by which an atom
or a molecule gains or loses verbs gangs
loses verbs electrons during chemical
what changes verb also verb change in
physics is verb change is not a noun
okay
um and uh yeah ionization requires at
least two frames of the movie in this
case I showed three uh just to show that
it loses an electron okay that's the
official version and what is plasma
plasma is ionization a bunch of
ionizations that's all it is a bunch of
atoms doing what you're seeing there at
the bottom okay that's all it is it's
just here's ionization is one atom
plasma is many atoms doing ionization
and what is ionization let's say there
it's a process
what is plasma it's a process it's a
phenomenon there's something in motion
it's a running boy it's a flying eagle
it's a swimming bird
it's uh running uh galloping horse you
know it's all of those that's what
planet a jumping kangaroo like I like to
say okay so um yeah uh you look it up
you look up the definition of the word
state it says State a particular
condition that someone or something is
in what at a specific time
what does that mean it means a single
frame of the universal movie
there is no time in a single frame it's
the present you could say it's the
present Frozen
that's what a single frame or a specific
time means there is no interval of time
okay
state is a static concept okay state is
conceptually a cross-section of time in
the Universal movie there is no motion
embodied in a state there is motion
embodied in both ionization and plasma
therefore they do not they do not
qualify as a state okay motion two
locations or more than one location of
an object
um best way to memorize it State equal
State ich static okay static one frame
of the universal movie that's what a
state is okay so
um let's get that right okay if you
don't understand that well I can't help
you any further it means that you too
probably got a little bit of uh the
scarecrow's brain out there
okay the smell continues and he gives us
all kinds of examples of why plasma is
not a state plasma contains what charged
something in motion particles charge is
a phenomenon Something In Motion these
charged particles sets plasma apart from
other states of matter exactly plasma is
superheated okay it's heated heated
means motion electrons are wet ripped
away verb rip is a verb means you're
taking something away from something you
cannot uh synthesize rip in a single
frame of the universal movie
an ionized gas again ionized is a verb
okay plasma glows glows is a verb motion
examples of plasma include lightning
lightning is electricity it's something
in motion you cannot take a snapshot of
lightning because what you took a
picture of is really electricity flowing
and they call that image lightning and
people confuse the image the still image
with what that uh bright
um Ray represents which is electricity
excited gas excited verb solar wind what
is wind moving air or in this case uh
moving you know whatever is out there
welding arcs and Arc uh again
electricity
okay so all these and contain motion
plasma is a form of matter in which many
of the electrons what wander wander verb
it's motion means it goes everywhere
wander around the electrons in a solid
liquid or gas stay with the same atomic
nucleus which is not what happens to the
um plasma just as a liquid will boil
changing into a gas heating a gas will
form a plasma you must heat the gas okay
so plasma does have a history because
the word plasma includes the history of
heating it is a process you have to see
before and after to conceptualize the
word plasma for the purposes of physics
a soup of charged what is charged motion
particles ions and negatively charged
particles electrons so yeah plasma is a
thing in motion and so uh you cannot
isolate the motion or plasma from its
motion because the word embodies motion
it's part of the definition of the word
plasma so it's got to do with grammar
not with what you think plasma is oh I
took a picture of plasma no you did not
take that's in ordinary speech in
science you cannot take a picture of
plasma because plasma is defined as
motion you cannot take a picture of
motion that's the issue okay you take a
picture of the boy running or you took a
picture of a boy that's all we see in
the picture we don't see him running and
the Running part is the part that you
cannot isolate from plasma
okay here's uh one fellow and he says
the following he says that there are not
only four states of matter meaning
plasma be in the force he said there's a
five there's a fifth one
okay let's find out there are five known
phases
phases phases doesn't sound like uh the
same thing as a state so phase and State
uh do not uh compute phase is something
that happens state is something that is
so phase is not a state but these people
are now very particular about you know
uh grammar and so they they skip over
these uh nuances these uh these little
things these details okay uh of matter
Solace liquids gases and he includes
plasma and he also includes something
called Bose Einstein condensates
what are these bozos these Bozo
condensates what are these it says the
main difference in the structure of each
state is in the densities of the
particle
so he's saying the issue here is just
density okay so there we have a solid
and it's got all these atoms or
molecules whatever you want to see that
as uh atoms is fine so we have all these
atoms close together and they're they
don't move they don't vibrate they don't
flow and we call that a socket okay and
then we have liquid they're farther
apart okay we don't have to see them
moving again liquid you can see milk on
the floor and say that's a liquid no
problem gas same thing as a category I
just showed you that you can take a
snapshot of gas it doesn't have to be
moving we call that gas smoke you take a
picture of smoke that's gas okay
but uh plasma you know you have the
ionization you have to have the
electrons coming out so people say what
did you take a picture of there Bill
well I don't know we don't have a name
for it because they call it plasma like
it says there but that ain't plasma
because I don't know what happened
before I need the history of what
happened before in order to
conceptualize the word the word plasma
okay but he's got a bozo einsteini
condensate what is that
well that's just all the atoms closer
together
that's all it is so it looks like a
solid
this bozo
okay so all we have is this bozo
condensate it's just a uh just another
form of solid it's a salad it would fall
under the category of solid but let's
make sure we you know cover that base
well here it is okay uh The Bozo
condensate gas is cooled to low density
a hundred thousand times less dense than
air
okay so all they did was freeze
something you know and they call that a
uh Bozo condensate great and what is
that well that's a solid but then they
clarify what this thing is okay and they
say the state of the Bose Bose
Bosa the Bose Einstein condensate is
described by a wave function
and there you see a wave function
but it doesn't look like it's standing
still looks like it's moving
so if that's a Bose Einstein condensate
and it's a wave function and a wave
function is something in motion because
it's an equation an equation only always
ever
represents something in motion there is
no equation that gives you any uh static
you get one point but then you throw
another variable in there another one or
a constant or whatever you change
something in the equation to get a curve
which is motion what you're putting is
dots that show some kind of motion all
equations only represent motion okay
and so uh yeah the wave equation is a
equation of a wave and there you see it
in motion so obviously if that's what a
condensate is
it looks like it ain't a solid either
it's simply a liquid
I don't know what to call it because
again uh if if it's a liquid it's got to
be you got to be able to take a snapshot
of it
and if it's a gas you got to be able to
take a snapshot of it and here I'm not
sure if I can take a snapshot of that
because I would get you know some
uh some image there and I wouldn't know
what that is and that would not be a
wave function in order to be a wave
function I got to see it moving then
it's a wave wave is always a verb okay
okay so uh not very good because now we
don't know if this uh bozo is a solid
or a wave
could be one of the two okay let's find
out well here um here we have
a definition of what let me put it over
here
of what a wave function is says wave
function may be taken to be a the
position coordinates of the particles
over position space
the momentum of all the particles over
momentum space okay and there you see
definition of momentum space is the set
of all momentum vectors vectors is
motion uh p a physical system can have
okay the momentum Vector of a particle
corresponds to its motion
motion motion motion motion all these
people are talking about motion so the
only issue that we have to uh
resolve for the purposes of physics is
whether this bozo this Bose Einstein
Bose ioni I'd like to Bozo irony
condensate that that's good uh whether
that is a solid or whether it's a wave
if it's a wave it's neither it's not a
it's not a state because it's not a
solid a liquid or a gas if it's a solid
it would just fall under solids and so
in that case there's still one of the
three states of matter so I'm not sure
what this fifth state is no such thing
as a fifth state of matter okay uh
here's the
uh these this um
uh Jose both
uh Bose Einstein condensate according to
the Wikipedia this is what it looks like
yeah and this they go through this they
say uh
well let's uh wait till it starts again
so GIF here
and I guess each atom has its own energy
and is able to move freely okay when the
gas has cooled down the atoms slow down
and their energies decrease that's it
all you're doing is cooling a bunch of
atoms very low temperature this is very
low temperature all the bosons are able
to be a same energy in the same Quantum
State okay and they all form a single
Collective Quantum wave called a Bose
Einstein condensate
that's it so now the question is are you
staring at a wave or are you staring at
a solid okay let's look at it one more
time here it goes all these uh atoms
they're just gonna freeze
get closer together and they form this
uh
pancake a wave right so it looks like
it's moving so if a condensate is a Move
Motion uh that's one thing if on the
other hand it's a you know it's a still
image
well they have to tell us what it is
okay uh you know it's it's up to the
quantum folk to Define what a condensate
is is it is it a wave is it a solid is
it in motion or not
if it's uh standing still it belongs to
solids
and if it's a wave that's moving well it
ain't the liquid or a gas because
liquids don't move until they do
okay gases don't move until they do you
don't need Motion in gases liquids or
solids to define the category okay when
you look at milk on the floor you say
that's a liquid
is it moving no not yet but you can have
it moving if you want right
okay so here's the the issues is uh
either the Bose uh any condensate is it
a solid or is it a wave is it something
in motion or is it
something that is standing still
but standing still would look pretty
much like a solid that's all it is
okay but if it's a wave of some kind
well that does not qualify as a state
therefore it's not the fifth state or
the sixth State or the seventh state of
matter okay
turns out that
um there are more categories as well
said there's only five states of matter
here's the Wikipedia it mentions all
these states of matter that the quantum
Pope found they created all these
categories just to complicate themselves
and all of these have nothing to do with
science they only have to do with
technology and people don't know the
difference between science and
technology these people are simply
seeing something in the lab which they
cannot explain they don't care about
explaining it they just give names to
what to different phenomena and then
they put it out there and say oh we
found this new phenomenon and uh the
only question anybody asks is what can
we use it for how can I can make money
with it and I'm going to look at this
one for mionic condensate okay and uh
let's look at this one
give me a second here
what is this well oh Jesus
give me a second
get smaller
move myself talking about moving me
okay here we go uh
a little more
okay sorry about that
anyways this is from I think the
Wikipedia says a firm ionic condensate
or Fermi direct uh condensate is a super
what fluid
super fluid
phase phase two frames of the universal
movie formed formed verb by firm ionic
particles at low temperatures
temperatures is a phenomenon no such
thing as a photograph of temperature
superfluid what is it fluid with zero
viscosity and here we have
um somewhere here
I think I have it uh
is it this one
no
okay anyways uh I was going to show
viscosity but somehow I lost it
okay anyways viscosity simply uh has got
to do with how much friction there is
with the environment whatever's around
it but anyways um
it flows without any loss of what
kinetic energy that means you're talking
about something that flows when we're
talking about firm ionic condensate and
super fluid again
vortices continue to what rotate
indefinitely
so this is a fluid
of some kind okay but if it's a fluid
it's not a state
so they say this is the sixth state of
matter no it ain't it ain't because it's
not a state okay so uh yeah we've got a
little bit of problems with with this it
doesn't fall under the category so
neither plasma uh the Bose uh Einstein
condensate or the Fermi direct
condensate none of these are States
okay they're not States
and uh so again here I show this The
Firm ionic Fermi direct condensate
there's nothing but a cold liquid they
freeze the liquid
but it uh or or you know the atoms but
it has this ability to flow like a
liquid
without losing any energy that's that's
the phenomenon they discovered great for
technology has no purpose whatsoever in
science we cannot explain anything with
this we cannot explain how the universe
works with this in other words you would
have to the other way around you would
have to explain why this is the case
what causes that to happen
okay and of course they don't know
because they use words like frequency
that they don't understand all Concepts
so mathematical concept field and so on
so yeah they cannot explain the cause of
why this is so and they don't care what
they do is they just see some phenomenon
in the lab like in the 19th century they
saw electricity and they say oh we can
use this yeah that's technology it's got
nothing to do with science you cannot
use electricity a word electricity to
explain something what you need to do is
explain electricity
how does that phenomenon happen is it
the flow of little electron beads from
atom to Adam like some bozos say out
there
the bozos who came up with this nonsense
they keep believing that it's a flow of
electron beads from Adam to atom that's
the explanation we have today of
electricity
okay so what are some conclusions we can
say that there are three states of
matter that's all there is okay solid
liquid gas we're done that's it you can
take a picture of any of those you can
take a snapshot of a solid of a liquid
or an orbit gas
okay stop period we're done
uh Bose Einstein Condon said is uh
either a solid or a wave if it's a solid
it falls under solids it's not a fourth
state it's the first state you can save
solid is the first state if it's a wave
it ain't any of them it's not a state
period
uh for me to Rack uh condensate same
thing uh it's a cold liquid if if it
flows we don't care because it's not a
state and before it flows you can say
well we got something there
well I don't know what you got what do
you have you have a liquid do you have a
solid is it in gaseous form you tell us
and whichever one you choose you're just
going to put them under one of those
three categories if it starts flowing
and the flowing is the condensate it's
the Fermi direct condensate it's not a
state
okay plasma is not a state okay
um the state is one frame of the
universal movie motion requires two or
more than one okay plasma is a process
and there you can see that you can take
a picture of a chair uh any liquid on
the floor you know puddle uh any gas you
can take a snapshot
out there in space if necessary those
you can take a snapshots of because the
words do not embody motion it's a single
frame of the universal movie on the
other hand
plasma
you require at least two frames of movie
because plasma has it embodies the word
ionization in it plasma means is defined
as
ionized gas you need to do something to
the gas so the history is included
within plasma cannot avoid it
okay
okay folks uh
let's look at uh our um science critic
this uh fellow
he um
made him a 45 minute video
and in it he criticized the scientific
method the genuine scientific method and
one of the issues the one he brought up
in this uh segment of his film is
whether science is knowledge that's one
issue and then the other secondary issue
is whether knowledge is belief
it's just another a more a stronger
belief is that what knowledge is
okay so let's find out what he says here
it is let me put him on you'll hear him
in his own words okay
let's see if I can set him in motion
here he goes
the questions and issues to be addressed
in this rebuttal include
is science about knowing about knowledge
and his knowledge merely a stronger
belief
is science about knowledge well it
certainly looks like it has something to
do with that doesn't it if knowledge is
Justified true belief then doesn't that
mean that it was always belief but at
the end of the day science is all about
furthering knowledge
okay so he went around in circles he
says uh knowledge um science is now
lives now Liz is believed perhaps he
didn't address that and then without
also the without defining knowledge
either he just says well then uh you
need more knowledge to have more science
that's all he said not very uh smart
fellow at all okay but uh let's address
what he said
um because we have to address uh what he
failed to do which is first let's define
knowledge we look up the word Wikipedia
says the following says often defined as
true belief
okay there is a wide agreement among
philosophers that it is a form of what
true belief
okay despite the agreement about the
general characteristics of knowledge
listed above many deep disagreements
remain regarding its exact definition
so here we are 2 000 plus years after uh
Plato defined as Justified true belief
or something along those lines and uh
there still cannot be are not are unable
to define the word knowledge that's
interesting and we're talking about
philosophers and whoever you know
English Majors whoever's out there
dictionary writers they cannot Define
the word knowledge
while there is wide agreement among
philosophers that uh propositional
knowledge is a form of true belief many
controversies in philosophies focus on
justification on whether it's a
Justified true belief whether the belief
is Justified so they work on that
justified issue whether it is needed at
all how to understand it and whether
something else besides it is needed and
uh dictionary.com says what is the
opposite of knowledge unbelief
yeah it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable that after so many
hundreds of years thousands of years
they haven't figured out what knowledge
is this is what Stanford Encyclopedia of
philosophy has to say about it
traditional approach uh approaches to
knowledge habit that knowledge has to do
with factors like truth and
justification whether knowledge requires
safety uh sensitivity reliability or
independence from certain kinds of luck
has proven controversial but something
that all these potential conditions are
not seem to have in common is that they
have some sort of intimate connection
with belief
although it is admittedly difficult to
make the relevant connection precise
there is an intuitive sense in which
every Factor we've examined as a
candidate for uh being relevant to
knowledge has something to do with
beliefs
so what does Stanford say well that it's
belief okay everybody says that
knowledge is just belief whether it's
Justified whether it's true we don't
care about any of that it's believed
that's the key word uh belief and
knowledge are synonyms you could say
that knowledge just
um a stronger belief that people have I
have a stronger belief that God exists
I caught knowledge I know God exists and
what did you say you just said that you
have a stronger belief than the guy
who's an atheist so it's just a question
of degrees how strong is your belief you
know
you know and um so here's uh for you to
take this is your take away what you can
take home with you these are the issues
etymology of science is
knowledge I think it's the way it's
pronounced uh in Latin so it comes from
Syrian meaning to no
that's how our forefathers Define
knowledge and they did a lousy job of it
okay they had no idea what they were
talking about uh because science has
nothing to do with knowledge but let's
assume let's concede and say that it
does okay is science knowledge that's
the first question you should ask if
science is all about knowledge gaining
knowledge accumulating knowledge you
know perfect okay let's define it that
way is knowledge belief well all these
people say it's belief in 2000 years
they haven't redefined or changed the
definition that uh Plato had and they
still can't agree and they don't have a
definition they could put in front of
you and then if science is knowledge and
knowledge is belief is science belief
is that what science is about
hopefully
um belief belongs to religion it's got
to do with opinion with something
personal or something subjective whereas
science is an objective explanation in
the case of physics of a mechanism
you tell someone how something happened
you know like uh
uh my famous test you know you let go of
the pencil
and it falls to the ground and you
explain in your own words how you think
that happened
you make a movie of it it's objective
what's objective is the movie your
belief of it is something else or my my
belief in it those are something else
the the
explanation the mechanism I showed
that's objective I can make a movie of
it you can watch it and say okay I
understand what you are proposing
doesn't mean you have to believe it but
you have to understand what I just
showed you and uh that's that's not
called knowledge it's called explanation
that's what science is science is
explanation knowledge that belongs
completely to religion because that has
to do with belief as these people have
said okay
okay so uh here we have uh I'm not gonna
go through many
um
comments and questions because I have
addressed some of those almost all of
them related to uh plasma so what I'll
do is I'm gonna just look at a couple
which uh caught my eye if I missed one
of the ones that you wanted answered uh
just post it one more time and I'll see
if I can address it okay so here's the
first one says Faraday was not a
mathematical physicist that's for sure
you know Arie just uh put him in that
position then Erie died and this fell
inherited
um uh you know the the job
almost no math absolutely in fact it was
uh Maxwell who did the math later on and
not a faraday however lines of force do
not exist it's a concept
well big problems here the first one is
the word exist we don't know what you
mean by exist and until you define the
word exists we will not know what you
said when you say lines of force do not
exist so there's the first task here's
the second task we have these two
gentlemen one is fair they and the other
one is Maxwell first one says I cannot
conceive of curved lines of force
without the conditions of a physical
existence in that intermediate space and
I'm sure Mr Fair they knew a little more
about magnetism than you do okay so um
yeah he talked about the existence of
something physical those lines of force
are physical
and so again you need to define the word
exist so we know what you mean when you
say that they don't exist and the other
one or that they're a concept that'd be
nice for you to Define as well uh you're
saying that these lines are just
Concepts well these Concepts move things
around and as far as I'm concerned no
concept does
and then a good old Maxwell he says feel
the space in the neighborhood of the
electric and magnetic bodies in that
space again there is matter in motion
matter in motion okay so these two
gentlemen uh contradict this uh first
fellow who says that lines of force are
a concept and uh or concepts or whatever
plural and that they don't exist if
they're concepts for sure they don't
exist because no concept exists or can
be said to exist in science that's the
first issue but then the other issue is
okay so uh the lines of force that we
can't see but are within these two
magnets right
uh they don't exist but somehow those
lines of force that don't exist
that you know are not there uh they they
pull one one man is pulling on the other
yeah
uh
yeah yeah one magnet pulls on another
and it does it through these lines of
force whatever they are and so if they
don't exist what is it uh Magic Black
Magic is that what exists in between two
magnets
it's because these people uh harp upon
see and touch they think that if you
can't see it or touch it it doesn't
exist
and that's not the definition of the
word exists that's why we require that
you define the word exist and tell us
what these lines of force are
because uh two people who uh outrank you
Mr Faraday and Mr Maxwell they said yes
they do exist there is matter in Motion
in there
and another fellow along the same line
says physics physicists a hundred years
ago seem to understand the phenomena
better than physicists today magnetic
forces appear to be caused by in all
cases by circulating currents
circulating he thinks those are
circulating currents
okay uh these currents seem to create
regions of high pressure
and low pressure as Maxwell laid out so
this is pressure
I thought was pushing these guys are
pulling so I'm not sure pressure against
what are they pushing against the
outside and that's why they're coming in
what pressure the word pressure doesn't
even belong here okay and the details
are extremely complex for sure for sure
for you for the underlying mechanism at
least seems clear
um well if it's so clear to you and you
say that it's what uh uh circulating
currents what is a current
is it the flow of electrons
because that's where people out there
think uh the people in Quantum and if uh
electricity which is what current is all
about right is the flow of beads how the
how does the flow of beads produce
attraction
that's what you got to explain so if you
say that you know the mechanism you know
that it's what causes this attraction
and you're saying it's related to
current and current is the flow of
electron beads from one atom to the next
please explain how the flow of beads in
One Direction attracts a magnet
uh that's you know at a distance from
this magnet that has the flow of beads
what's the mechanism
so no you don't understand and not a
single mathematician on planet Earth
understands how a magnet attracts
another they use the word field to mask
their ignorance and again that's just
masking their ignorance it's not telling
you how what the mechanism is uh that
produces the physical mechanisms that
produces attraction or repulsion
with that I'll see you next uh Sunday
and Merry Christmas to all of you we'll
see you then on Christmas